مع السلامة مرة أخرى ، تهانينا على
الفيلم الذي رأيته الليلة الماضية
مثير للغاية ومثير للغاية ، لقد
حصلت على نصيبك من أفلام الحركة
بما في ذلك الاستخراج ، كيف يكون هذا
الاستخراج مختلفًا أيضًا ،
أحب الفيلم الأول الذي أظن أننا
نرتقي فيه  بقدر ما
يتعلق الأمر بالحركة داخل الكاميرا ، فأنت تعلم
مثل الكثير من التأثيرات المرئية في الأفلام
هذه الأيام ، أعتقد أن الجمهور
أصبح مخدرًا تجاهه ، لكن لدينا أيضًا
عنصرًا عاطفيًا في الفيلم أعتقد أن
الأشخاص مرتبطون به ولكننا لم نفعل ذلك.  لقد قمنا
بتوسيعها حقًا في الفيلم الأول خارج
مشهد واحد ،
لذا في هذه التجربة في
الفيلم الثاني ، تمكنا من سرد
قصة الأصل مرة أخرى ، ويمكننا
الغوص حقًا في من كانت هذه الشخصية هي
التي جعلته يدق  ماذا حدث
مع طفله ، لماذا تركه ، نعم ، رئيس
الطفل ، عائلة الزوجة ، وهكذا ،
عندها يكون لديك
تكامل العاطفة
والعمل الذي يكملان بعضهما البعض ، فأنت
لا تهتم حقًا بهذا الإجراء
إلا إذا كنت  استثمرنا في
شخصياتهم إذا كانت وجهة نظر عاطفية
وكان هذا شيئًا كنا
نركز عليه حقًا هذه المرة وأعتقد
أن هذا ما يستجيب له الجمهور ، نعم ،
أنت محق في ذلك
في الواقع لقد تعرفنا على الشخصية
بشكل أفضل هذه المرة ولكن  إذا
رجعنا إلى مشاهد الحركة ، فكيف تصبح
لائقًا لذلك ، هل يجب أن تحب العيش في
صالة الألعاب الرياضية أو ما هو السر
أه قضيت الكثير من الوقت في التدريب على أي حال ،
فأنت تعرف ماذا لأنني أستمتع به
يساعدني على
الخروج منه  رأسي وجسدي
قليلاً كما تعلمون ويمكنني أن أميل إلى الإفراط في
التفكير في الأشياء ، لقد
انتهيت للتو من التفكير في الحب
والرعد ، لذلك كنت أكبر بكثير
في هذا الفيلم مما لم أكن أول
شخص لم
أفعله.  لدي الوقت الكافي لفقدان كل
الوزن بالضرورة ، لكنني
غيرت تدريبي بشكل جذري وانتقل من
معرفتك لأفكار كمال الأجسام الجمالية
ثم أصبح هذا يتعلق بالوظيفة
والحركة والمرونة
والتمكن من أن تكون متعدد الاستخدامات
والتكيف مع أي حركات مثيرة.  لقد
ألقيت بهم في الكثير من التدريبات على فنون الدفاع عن النفس
وكان من الرائع أن تعلم أنها
شعرت على الفور بأنها أخف وزنا وأكثر مرونة ، لقد
قللت من تناول السعرات الحرارية لم أكن
أحاول الاحتفاظ بمجموعة كاملة من الحجم الكبير ،
لقد كان الأمر مناسبًا لي بشكل
جيد  حالتي الطبيعية على ما أعتقد ، لكن ما
يقال إنه مرهق للغاية ،
فأنت تعلم الكثير من الإصابات التي كنت
أتعامل معها ، ولا بأس في بعض
الأيام الطويلة جدًا ، 14 ساعة يطلق النار في منتصف
الشتاء وبراغ في جمهورية التشيك ،
لكن هذا رائع أعتقد أنه يضيف قوة
و  الأصالة على الشاشة التي
يحترمها الجمهور ، أعتقد أنني كنت
أشاهدها بشكل كبير مثل هذا ليس
ممكنًا بشريًا ، نعم ، لم
نفكر في ذلك ، إما أو
أعني أن سام
هو مجرد عبقري مجنون لما
يريد أن يرتديه  الشاشة وما
يحاول وضعه على الشاشة ، تعلم أنه
كان هناك تسلسل لساحة السجن
300 عنصر إضافي أشعل النار فيه أشياء مشتعلة
وفي لقطة واحدة لم يتم
تحريرها من أربع أو خمس زوايا حيث
يمكنك  أنت تعلم أنه يمكنك تغطية الأخطاء ،
كان كل شيء موجودًا ، لذا إذا كان لديك شيء واحد
خارج الخط ، فعليك العودة
والبدء من جديد
ثم تسلسل القطار حيث
أنا على قمة القطار
يتحرك القطار 40 50 ميلاً  ساعة هناك
طائرة هليكوبتر 20 قدمًا أمام القطار وهي
تطير للخلف هذا كل شيء في الكاميرا ،
لا توجد تأثيرات خاصة لم يكن
هناك ما بعد الإنتاج كان هناك بالفعل
مرعب ومبهج ومكافئ ،
لقد بلغت الأربعين من العمر في أغسطس ،
وبالمناسبة نشارك  نفس عيد الميلاد الذي كان
رائعًا حتى 11 أغسطس.
نعم ، نعم ، نعم ،
عيد ميلاد سعيد مقدمًا YouTube ، لذا
شكرًا لك ، هل لديك أي خطط خاصة
لعيد الميلاد هذا أو العقد القادم ،
نعم فقط حاول عدم الانهيار
جسديًا وذهنيًا.
هذا مثير للاهتمام كما تعلمون كما لو
كنت في العشرينات من عمرك ، ما زلت تعتقد
أنك غير مرئي وستعيش إلى
الأبد ، ثم فجأة بالنسبة
لي على أي حال الآن أنا مثل أوه ، واو ،
هناك تاريخ انتهاء صلاحية وأنا أعلم
هذا واضح ولكني أعتقد أن
معظمنا يحاول ويفكر بطريقة ما أننا
سنخدعه أو نتغلب عليه ، كما تعلمون ، نعم ،
إدراك أنها
ستعود إلى المنزل ولكن
المعرفة التي لدي الآن حول
طول العمر حول إدارة
لياقتي العقلية  اللياقة البدنية
أكبر بكثير مما كانت عليه في أي وقت مضى وأم
نعم ، لذلك أشعر من نواح كثيرة بأنني أكثر
صحة وأقوى مما كنت أفعله في
سنوات شبابي ، كما تعلمون لمجرد أنني
أذكى قليلاً في كيفية التعامل معها ،
أعتقد نعم ، حسنًا ،
شكرًا  أنت كثيرًا على وقتك ،
أعتقد أن وقتنا قد انتهى ، ولكن
سؤال سريع ، هل سنراك في أي
أفلام رومانسية ننتظرها كنساء ،
أحب أن أقول هذا طوال
الوقت أعتقد أن الرقم واحد  الشيء الذي
أحب أن أفعله هو قصة حب
وليس من
خارج مني عدم النظر إلى مجرد الحصول على
هذا والاطلاع على مكتبي ، كما تعلم ، أود أن أفعل ذلك
حقًا ،
سأكون حقًا شيء تعرفه بنفس
القدر  كرحلة إبداعية وعملية
لتحدي
نفسك وتكون جزءًا من
شيء مختلف وغير مألوف
سيكون من الرائع القيام به على الشاشة ،
أنتظر تلك التهاني على
الفيلم والتحدث معك بشكل لطيف للغاية ، شكرًا
جزيلاً لك
أجنبي